nicki minaj has stayed pretty quiet on
the music front
after welcoming her son last year her
last solo track was february 2020
but today she released her 2009 mixtape
beam me up scotty
on all streaming services yes i i tried
to play at the house while the kids were
working
and they quickly realized that maybe
that was not the best parenting move
i've ever made
so then i i went to another room but i
will say
it's kind of amazing yeah it features 23
tracks
some are hearing these songs for the
very first time it does include a brand
new track called seeing green which is
really amazing with drake and lil wayne
and last night on instagram live nicki
created or credited drake
for getting her out of that as you
mentioned before that writer's block
he single-handedly got me out of my
writer's block and i'm never gonna
forget it and i'ma shout it to the
world from the mountaintops because
that's the real that's my hand to god
he sent me something and it made me feel
so competitive again i was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing like get like
you need to start writing it and
whenever i hear drake and wayne rap it
just
it's always going it inspires something
in me but outside of drake's
raps it's his like pep talks he'll he'll
send one text that'll make me really
like reevaluate everything he's a
[ __ ] genius
as a musical artist but also just as a
human
like please everybody know that like
that's real like that's very exciting
um and so i love you very much it didn't
feel right with you not being on it
that's really the best way i could put
it it was like
it was fun the other way but it's it's
it's epic this way you know
so i just we just you know i had some
real heart to heart to you lately like
just about
the fact that it's like it's just your
world nobody doesn't shut it in you and
it's like
when you're gone you know obviously papa
bear's here now so we are you know
we understand the priorities but you
know when you're gone
i'm not gonna lie like i'm sure i speak
for everybody in the live when it's like
yo we really miss you like
we really miss your presence and just
like we missed the bars
we miss the excitement that you bring
uh tony asks is drake driving no he was
literally walking around west hollywood
that's where he was but
he was just walking pulsar says drake is
so hot uh
eva says no more nikki please and he
says nikki has been through a lot and
i'm proud of her continuing after a lot
of the hardships she's been through
unless she's posting uh throwbacks
so excited that nikki's back i'm very
excited i
i agree with drake and how often do i
get to say that in my life i agree with
you
but i i do i feel like there was a big
hole when she disappeared i mean you
said it yourself graham
it it felt like she was away for a
really long time and
you know you said she was only been away
since but february
um yeah last year so
i i i've certainly felt that void but i
also when one of the songs i loved
hearing
um the one with drake i just grabbed
this quote
listen to this i'm a star in your room
i'm the standout you just the stand-in
ooh that's [ __ ] stuff let's then
these can't say the word copy my
homework
that's my private that's the airports i
landed
i'm just going to leave that there this
is the stuff we've missed
this is the stuff that gets us excited
can we please immediately post that clip
on social media cheryl hickey
reading nicki minaj just reading it out
i'm just saying that i want to make it
beats
i love her confidence i love that she
loves music this much
i love that she's got found her
confidence again
and that you know it took some time she
had a baby she's
you know growing her family and her
friends came back and said listen
we're missing you out there fans are
missing you there's enough room
for multiple women in this space and i
think
her playing the game and getting this
all rolling again
is really important because there's lots
of room for women at the top it's a
landscape it's not like this
it goes like this and there's tons of
room and i'm here for and i'm glad she's
back
yeah postal says nikki is the real deal
i can tell she writes her own uh raps
uh el says yeah nikki's father just died
she needed time to heal or find a new
normal losing a parent especially
unexpected is hard god bless her yeah i
mean we had the whole feud with cardi b
and i hope
like she leaves that behind because it
some of it struck me as a little bit of
insecurity on nicki's part that someone
else was rising like you just said
there's room for multiple female rappers
now we've seen cardi and megan the
stallion like they were both going hard
the last couple years and they did a
song together
like i mean there's no issues there
whatsoever so hope nikki yeah it's
coming back to a place where
she realizes she doesn't have to be
threatened by the other
female rappers so yeah i think it's
gonna be an interesting space that nikki
returns to yeah she says she's working
on
a new album because yeah she hasn't done
an album since 2018 so i'm excited to
hear
what she's gonna yeah bring to the table
so yeah yeah like i love nikki being
in the game so it's nice to have uh her
back
yeah i totally agree i think there's
there's lots of room
i love that she's bantering back and
forth talking about
you know them every other artist being
the stand-in she's the standout i think
it's great